that's good to see you have you been
doing during that I guess in the last
two months late that we've all been
stuck indoors well I mean I like to be
stuck I like to be alone so I'm okay
yeah everyone happy and healthy over
there yes yes that's good it's such an
interesting time for communication and I
think what you're doing with jasmine is
it's the right time you know where all
these interviews are happening over zoom
everyone's connecting online almost at
least personally more than you would do
when you're just doing it in real life
people are really looking for a
connection right now that I think I mean
that was never it was a fluke really
because we were about to launch we're
gonna launch at this time anyway so it's
a fact that it's launching at this time
during this time is really feels like
destiny a little bit because it's it's a
great way to communicate these are those
exactly about what it is and how does
that how does she has no work well I
mean jasmine is the only place for their
users and influencers can talk directly
about any subject and you're talking to
you a person which is looking into your
eyes and it's not necessarily an expert
it's just of another human being that
you can ask questions to it's just it
feels like there's a lot of emotional
connections that are made and I think
people are really hungry for that I mean
eating outside of kovat keeping a little
hungry for you know connection and
that's kind of been one of my passions
is to try and you know and probably part
of my downfalls in such a romantic and
always looking for ways to help people
be there you know foam or or make their
relationships more interesting and stay
together and I don't know even among you
know in in the modern era where it's so
easy to connect or to say to connect
digitally right you have all these
platforms you really think still that
they didn't really help people actually
connect to each other
why don't you social media is from far
enough and that's why I mean again I was
always concerned about um the lack of
intimacy when it came to technology but
I think we need to embrace the
technology romanticize the present the
future stuck romanticize in the past
here we are this is what we get to deal
with let's try and find the
call to complement our relationships you
know even make ourselves more
interesting you know just kind of even
practice with other people what were you
no communication it just it's just um I
think it's got so much opportunity and
when I first was aware of jasmine and
they came to me about being the creative
director and really getting involved I
stopped you know yes do you know
webcamming is very misunderstood and
there's also some red flags and going
well but I like red flags I like it how
can we use this for to make it positive
because 50 million people a day are
going on to these sites and some of
people are having even secret
relationships or secret you know social
media excitement of you know
relationships why not bring it into the
open bring it into our relationships and
um you know not make it so bad or or you
know and just kind embrace it and see
where it goes so kind of remove the
stigma of people talking to each other
over webcam or presenting to an audience
over webcam I mean it's I guess what you
were saying just now is like the idea
was that it was for things that were
sort of salacious maybe but you
shouldn't be looking it that way no I
mean no but it's about everything and we
can talk about you know beauty it knows
things you're anything you know things
you're interested in you know things
sometimes it's easier to talk to a
stranger sometimes then even your best
friend you know just kind of get an idea
of you know an opinion that's not um you
know know this so I think that it's an
interesting opportunity to really kind
of get that human connection flowing
again and you know there is this
epidemic of loneliness I feel and people
are already isolated in so many ways and
isolating themselves that this might be
a little breakthrough I think I mean I
think it's they're pioneers so just I
think it's really an opportunity but
it's also you know it's just it's
everything that's interesting is risky
so I just think hmm enjoy it and and try
and use this kind of platform for good
activism look about all of the things
people are interested in and get the
human connection because you're not just
typing texting you know you're you're
actually communicating with somebody
one-on-one or in a group chat or
whatever it is and you're looking at
people
and that really makes a big difference
do you think yeah oh I agree I think
even even in the climate that we're in
right now this this whole endeavor that
we're doing the walls are sort of coming
down in a way that they're not even when
you're in person during an interview
someone yes exactly I mean listen feels
more intimate I'm awesome you know
sitting here and you go through the
whole process but we were looking at
each other talking having a conversation
you know they'd be listening but it's it
feels I don't know is a new you know
what it's here this is what technology
has done technology is part of nature
now it's not just something we're trying
to deny we have to embrace it yeah it
wasn't too long ago I remember hearing
like the first few times that couples I
knew got together by meeting online and
it seemed it's kind of like a lifetime
ago now but at the time it seemed
there's such a strange thing what you're
doing now you feel like people will be
easily finding love online this is
something that you're open to right well
I mean it's not a dating app or website
it's about just communication and and
creating relationships like friendships
and and talking to multiple people just
like you would with friends and I think
that's really missing I think that's
just missing in people's lives if it's
if it's older people if it's young
adults or just you know I was hoping
that if you made University Cambridge
and Oxford actually about kind of even
the dangers of even just changes of
pornography and things like that online
and how that if that's taking the place
of relationships that could be a bad
thing but this is completely different
this is just open communication with
somebody people that you're meeting
online and influencers it could be
experts in certain fields or they could
be did you talk about anything yeah now
it was super interesting I think right
now with people not being able to go
necessarily into production
traditionally as we've seen these
reunions of people on zoom or on these
so there are other platforms different
casts coming together
is there a cast that you've been a part
of that you would like to do one like
when we see a Baywatch or VIP like zoom
reunion last unions
that's as much as you possibly can but
you know I miss everybody I mean even on
the IP and VIP we were really close we
had a really close crew and cast on that
show as well yeah I miss everybody on
that show but I'm I kinda like to do new
things I just did a virtual photo shoot
which was really interesting never done
that before so cool people are taking
this to say okay and artists are
thinking this is what I have to work
with and I'm just gonna make the best of
it and so we're finding out we're
finding all these new things cool yeah
um we've been seeing Brandon we've been
seeing your son have a bit of a break on
on reality TV what's a bit like for you
seeing that happen well he's on the
hills and I always say you know people
people an incredible actor he's very you
know he's taking a lot of acting classes
he's very ambitious he's done some Jones
movies and he's really here's no rule it
some people would say don't do reality
TV if you want to be taken seriously as
an actor but Brandon is like a chameleon
he's just
invincible he's incredible I'm talented
person and he actually did a
conversation today online about
addiction and thinks he's really
passionate about he's just I love
listening to him like so proud that he's
taking on causes and and he that he's
talented and ambitious and gorgeous and
all those good things
music you know I'm very lucky to have
any disaster but you know it turns out
it's been a disaster but it wasn't there
you think you'll you'll make an
appearance a little guest appearance on
the next season oh who knows who knows I
don't know I mean I don't even know if I
can cross the border let's start there
right all right well you'll have to do a
little like a Jasmine integration where
you get to get that in the show then we
can see you on is there anything that
you wanted to say finally before we go
to you know all the people that are
putting their lives on the line right
now and people that are out there
helping in the hospitals and not just in
the hospitals to like delivering food or
doing all those sort of regular things
that maybe we have taken for
granted up until this time what does a
lot of heroes on the front line and I
always I try to support heroes on the
front line if anything if it's a natural
disaster this is you know I'm terrible
pandemic and you know we don't want to
it gets a little funny when people are
talking about the celebrity is what are
you doing doing there you know isolation
it's just who cares I care more about
the people on the front lines that are
risking their lives I mean there's a
story every day there for the news to
cover and how these people are are doing
such great work and saving lives
yeah it's a it's a difficult difficult
time and hopefully it's I don't know if
return in the corner yet I'm not quite
sure you know how I feel about
everything and what's really happening
but I guess everybody has their own
opinions we just have to get through it
together